vous allez devenir la plus grande icône
commercial des circuits film publicité
parrainage de produits catia
vous pensiez être déjà célèbres ou pas
nous serons fabuleusement riche qu'est
ce que vous essayez de me dire monsieur
vous ne courrez pas cette saison
chaque fois que vous perdez vous fait du
tort
je suis navré votre carrière arrive à
son terme
on ne peut espérer qu'une chose c'est
que cette course ne soit pas sa dernière
c'est moi qui déciderai quand
j'arrêterai
comment tu te sens je peux pas retourner
sur les circuits recommencer comme avant
ça marchera plus on peut pas aller
contre le progrès tu sais ce que je
ferais moi j'ai pas gagné mais je suis
trop contente de vous entraîner
j'adore les défis d'ailleurs je vous ai
baptisé mon projet senior avant
ouais
la plage ma avaler sharon stone a établi
un nouveau record aujourd'hui en
enregistrant le meilleur temps jamais
réalisé
vous êtes au courant du monde lorsque
store vient de battre un visage et
d'épreuves passerelle car oui
c'est ma dernière chance cruz la
dernière si je suis battu
aucun sponsor ne voudra engager
n'ayez pas peur de l'échec ne partez pas
battu d'avancé vous avez votre chance
quand je regardais à la télé on aurait
dit que vous
et que vous n'aviez pas peur de rien
j'aurais voulu connaître cette sensation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il sera jamais aussi rapide que ce temps
tu vas être plus malin que lui
je ne connais que la course comme
récompense le reste je m'en fiche et la
probabilité d'une victoire de storm est
de 95 2%
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]